[Music]
[Music]
hi everybody thanks so much for coming
out i am nick gillespie and this is
faisal saeed amitar and melissa chen it
should be on melissa but hi don't talk
yet so um we are going to be uh
recording the reason interview uh with
these two guys they co-founded five
years ago a non-profit called ideas
beyond borders and their basic thing
that they started out uh doing was
translating books about pluralism
science of liberties and critical
thinking and i'm talking about books
like jon stewart mills on liberty uh and
stephen pinker's enlightenment now into
arabic and then they distribute them for
free as ebooks throughout the arab
speaking world arabic speaking world
they've also translated thousands of
wikipedia pages on the same topics and
made them available to an audience
desperately interested in new ways of
thinking about culture politics and
ideas faisal left iraq after extremists
killed his brother and threatened his
life and melissa was once a persona non
grata in her native singapore due to her
activism there
they're going to explain how they work
to prevent extremism and cancel culture
in the west as well as the east
idea beyond ideas beyond borders is also
actively helping afghans find refuge
from the taliban and is running a global
campaign against censorship at
nbandbooks.org which i highly recommend
you check out
um so
without further ado faisal melissa
thanks for coming in
thanks for having us
uh are you allowed to speak uh i think
he's not it's not the middle east
women can speak okay okay it's not even
midtown so you know
it's the lower east right
um faisal uh talk about
what was the aha moment when you
you know you wanted to create what
became ideas beyond borders
yeah i mean it's for me it's like a
given uh concern that i grew up in an
environment that forces you to think
about the subjects like extremism and
what when you see your first beheading
your first reaction is like you never
forget
actually that's there's some truth to
that um and you i mean from like growing
up inside kind of an environment that
forces you to
to think uh to really try to find
solutions to the environment around me
and my privilege in that regard is that
i grew up with kind of an educated
family my parents study in the uk so i
studied i learned english since
in baghdad i i was born in babylon and i
grew up in baghdad and and so then when
it sounds like a bob dylan sock
it's uh
a punk rock band yeah what uh what year
how old are you so i was born 1991 so
right after the first gulf war during
the sanctions that the us put
in iraq and then during the regime of
saddam hussein followed by the second
gulf war in 2003 um and the other
subject that's really what i'm touching
on this is the subject of information i
remember growing up in which me and my
dad had to go on the roof listening to
the radio that is banned by the saddam
hussein regime as like the punishment
for listening to radio or satellite
television sometimes death
so for me like the subject of both
information and the subject of how to
combat extremism is something that was i
would say
forced on me uh like i i
i think i wanted as a kid to be an to be
an
astronomer actually
um and then uh when you hear the first
rocket you're like [ __ ] i have to take
care of what's around here
and here i am yeah um melissa talk about
um how many how many books has ideas
beyond borders translated and what is
how do you distribute them i mean it's
one thing to say
you know you put them out as ebooks and
then send them out on the internet but
you know what does that actually mean
well it's also interesting like how we
actually have to acquire these books um
because you know we have to negotiate
for free
um arabic digital rights
from the authors involved and so you
know we've worked with people like
stephen pinker sam harris the
neuroscientist
all sorts of writers who have done books
on science and and philosophy
um and like the graphic novel that i
think it was atlas network that did
oh head redox um on on a chapter from
right john cena mills on liberty exactly
just ideas that we know are not you know
are not represented well in that part of
the world in that language i think that
part is very crucial um you know for so
long in in the middle east you've had um
censorship because of religious and
cultural reasons
and at the end of the day like it
decimates the publishing industry there
because writers learn how to anticipate
market pressures
and and they know what will happen if
books get i mean we all saw what
happened to salman rushdie the moment
ayatollah khomeini put a fatwa on his
book and and i think went
as it always does when people try to ban
things but but you have uh you know it
creates this culture of intimidation
because let's not forget the publishers
and translators that three of them were
actually assaulted and killed for for
simply touching that book right in milan
oslo and tokyo just from a fatwa right
and so so the the
effects are really pernicious
um and if you look at the numbers
uh a best seller in the arabic world
runs about like uh to to be considered a
best seller you have to sell about a
thousand books per year but the new york
times to be a bestseller it's it's 5
thousand in a week so that's kind of the
the disparity that that
i know you guys have a statistic about
the number of books that are translated
into arabic versus like spanish what
what is that number to give a sense of
kind of how closed off the arabic
language world is from new books yes
that's from the u.n development report
uh that said there are more books
translated to spanish in one year than
arabic in 1 000 years wow um
hopefully we're changing that so that
statistic is not as valid but but um i
mean as melissa was saying is like you
have the authoritarianism especially
after the first world war where the
um a lot of rise of arab nationalism and
things like that that censored any us
deformation followed by the nazis who
are
one of the reasons why you see a lot of
mayan camps and a lot of bookstores
around the middle east i just actually
came back from the middle east is is the
fact that the nazi germany used that
kind of region as a battlefield between
that and allied and then afterwards it
was the soviet union so you really got
the
worst both ideologies the world has ever
known communism and nazism uh spreading
over there using the translation method
um
and
it was actually one of my happiest
moments was seeing enlightenment now on
the front uh
of some of the stores that we work with
across the middle east and it's uh
ironic right or in a way you you have to
negotiate with the authors for the
arabic language rights but they're kind
of willing to give them up right they
are because they know that they won't be
able to make a profit um in that part in
in arabic they just they just know that
and so we're most of our books are
actually some of them we know we know a
bunch of [ __ ]
oh that's you but um
but but so our books are all digital
because that's a really easy way to
actually subvert censors like in in the
middle east you have various governments
like the kuwaiti government
you know they all have ministry of
information by the way like that's just
you know i mean up until like what last
we're getting i was gonna say that i was
gonna say that up until last week we
didn't have one um but but um all most
of the arab countries have either some
sort of ministry of culture ministry of
information some sort of moral police
and
you know they they put out just a list
of of books that um like even incubate
it's about 5 000 banned books
um
right
yeah
is that does it function at all like
that of you know when you have a long
list of whatever you do don't read these
books i'm telling you not these ones you
can read those yeah i mean
it does or it doesn't i mean the it
really depends on how authoritarian
someone like regimes gets
like in iraq like sometimes they used to
publicize the killing of people hot cell
like television
so when you do that when you go i guess
like saddam hussein
makes
a lot of theories he's like like he is
he's uh to call him uh a bad dictator as
an understatement like he was a
combination of again both nazism and
communism and all the bad ideologies
combined so he was he was willing i also
understand he was a mets fan
i i just learned that so something i
learned yeah um so so
it depends on like how far the but now
in this age what i think is very
beautiful about the the 21st century is
that this ability to circumvent
some of that
so in a way it's like ibb is like at the
right time at the right place to do the
work that we do because before it was
literally people like gets uh i mean
you're barely able to smuggle a
playstation i remember like growing up
and
to smuggle books that are banned only
very selected people are willing to take
high risk uh to actually just do it for
for for that well to your point nick i
will say because you know he said about
um he mentioned that whatever is banned
is always uh you know wanted which is an
arabic proverb i always have gum in my
mouth because i grew up in a country
where this was banned very famously
yeah so it's just i have a cheek pocket
i don't think i would have liked gum
because you know at all if i had grown
up here where it was like readily
available but because it was something i
couldn't have it has always held this
mystique for me and now i have a
permanent cheat pocket where i store it
um so do you uh do
what format do you put them in pdfs and
then people
you know i mean basically i mean do you
hide the file under false names and
things like that or is that giving away
too much so two um pdf and html html for
faster browsing lower speed internet and
also now we're working with organization
called bio forest and what does is that
it mirrors our websites across all the
world so the website is banned in one
country it can be allowed in the other
that came in as a result of actually
people notifying us that our website has
been banned in egypt and syria it's been
banned in syria multiple times which is
kind of a good sign means you're doing
your work
but at the same time like
we do our best to kind of adapt to the
new technologies um to i sometimes see
our books actually spreading in signal
so signal is a is an app that's heavily
now being used promoted by us a lot
across the region uh telegram and stuff
like that um so and that's what i think
that the book made it you mentioned like
on liberty um i sew it to like some
shady telegram channel and i mean
everything is the shade
but
but but on that specific thing it was
the shady that i like
um and i saw like our book there like
downloaded a couple thousand times so
but for what we do is that it's mostly
online and we also take into account
that the internet speeds there are not
as fast though which our best to make
the files smaller and be able to people
for that to navigate and do you have an
ad free app for this
for people
so far yeah because you're a non-profit
i mean and think it's like we we uh we
cannot because melissa saying about the
for-profit industry uh there is it's
still
very minimal but in my my last visit to
to the middle east i actually see that
something really worth mentioning is
that
how
like what we many of us here take for
granted like freedom of speech and stuff
like that people there are willing to
die for it
and and i met with like a book publisher
his dad was killed for selling books and
he was like this is now the mission of
my life is to actually build a
successful business model that actually
contains the publishing industry so i
think is that there is definitely the
will
uh and people are willing to
put like when i came to america i don't
want to talk so much about this whatever
came to america 10 years ago i thought
like these values were already accepted
freedom of speech the right for publish
all that stuff and to see americans
[ __ ] on it every day and then it's
like when you go there i'm actually
reminded of how important this value is
because these people are putting it
putting their lives on the line for it
and and so they are going to be i
believe like just from my list of
conversations is there's great demands
um enlightenment now is actually is
doing really well and john stewart mill
so there's people are willing to
buy the book out of support for the for
the publisher
um so i'm hoping that in the next couple
of years and we are supporting them
through our micro grant program etc to
kind of build that seed and they're able
to go on their own and then there will
be no need for us to do our work anymore
well recently actually at the baghdad
book fair we had a publisher in iraq
emails that was one book right what if
there was one book
that book you'll be surprised actually
funny
um no but but they actually a publisher
actually emailed us and said you know we
would actually like to print one of your
books which one
and it was believe it or not it was sam
harris's end of faith wow right and this
was like wow this was i'm like wow we
actually you know to have a publisher he
can be the most hated man on every
continent now right right no that's
fascinating though why did that why do
you think that book resonated or i think
it's it's just you know
if if it was up to this publisher to
negotiate for the rise to try to get
somebody to translate it which is
expensive
it he wouldn't have made a dime but but
because ivy had already done it
digitally the the the translation
already existed all he needed to do was
have the balls and really in that part
of the world that's what it requires uh
to print the book and to decide to
display it and to sell it um and so i i
see this as really changing the the
calculus for for people for for
publishers a very fledgling very
throttled industry
um and and you know this is
anachronistic right like because
back then like there was a time when the
arabic world was
flush with
pluralism and and and you know during
while europe was going through a dark
age um the arabic world was was kind of
the seed of the enlightenment there was
a period of time when that was the case
when
great libraries which by the way that's
what we named our online library after
was a house of wisdom which in arabic is
beitel hikma
which was a
beautiful library that existed in your
part of the world which my people sacked
right my neighbor my hood yeah the
mongols burned it down
sorry
and then and then it never really
recovered
um what um talk about where do you find
your translators and then how do you
compensate them because this is not an
easy task i mean melissa you were
talking about some of the uh translators
of rushdies the satanic verses were
killed were attacked and killed um
obviously you you are sourcing the
translation mostly in the middle east
right so yeah so how do you how do you
protect them how do you pay them and
things like that we have like i think
one day hopefully uh documentary will be
made
on our work but really we use a very
kind of anonymous protected system in
which we send the money to one country
in the middle east that gets sent um to
other countries and then when people
pick the money they don't have to show
any identification for them to receive
it so in that way so even sometimes we
deal as like we tell them oh this guy is
going to show up at 3 p.m come pick up
the money and this person shows up
without any actually knowledge about
what this money is about
and what's so what we're utilizing on is
that kind of the expat community that a
lot of people like live in germany who
send their money back to their families
in syria or in iraq and stuff like that
so this we we communicated that this is
kind of another way it's like oh my
cousin is sending my money from from
germany um
so far it's working
however i think the the
now there are some technologies being
involved
in signal and other places that might be
we also utilize
because that's in a way faster in a way
less reliant most of these systems are
reliant a lot of trust and and what what
happens is that you need to have a lot
of people who believe in the mission
willing to take a risk in their life to
actually do the work that we do uh the
question is i always try to reduce that
friction of how to
uh how to allow that in terms of how we
pick many of these people um i mean
there is a very as i said like a growing
movement
of people who have tried all forms of
authoritarianism they have lived under
socialism they have lived under islamic
isis and the likes and they're like [ __ ]
it we need something else
and they and when when kind of the first
i mean i
when i'm when i'm back well i'm like
every time back to iraq they call me
like the founding father of that kind of
movement even though i was like younger
at the time because we were the crazies
uh and when we were 15 and 16 and the
thing is that that movement
after 13 years coming back to my home
country it was
just so amazing to see that this
movement that we started actually now
have hundreds of thousands and many of
them actually adopted these skills
learning to do translation et cetera
some of them go to
graduate postgraduate degrees for them
to be able to do it so we put them
through a lot of tests a lot of ways in
which we make sure that these people are
aligned with our values and at the same
time also know that the profession and
one of the kind of the challenges with
with arabic translation goes back to the
kind of the statistic i mentioned is
that a lot of scientific vocabulary is
not available in arabic
because of the lack of scientific
research in many of those countries so
so if you think about the so there is a
we do have a group of advisors in
countries like afghanistan is actually
worse so in a way like makes iraq look
like the switzerland by by comparison to
to to afghanistan because like some
languages like pashtu mainly been used
for agriculture and and things like that
so there's almost nothing about
anything resembles enlightenment
philosophy and and so we we're light i
mean after the afghanistan disastrous
withdrawal there were a lot of
people professors at the university of
kabul america university of kabul who's
been lending us advice on link like how
to invent a word and where to uh because
again like in languages like pashtu
almost there's almost nothing for uh for
a lot of the terms that we take here for
granted so that's really one of the
extra challenge when it comes to
translating these languages when you're
translating mainly like non-fiction and
scientific materials or philosophical
because they're the terminology is not
there for it
um wait faceoff i remember so we
actually recently translated barry
wise's book how to fight um
anti-semitism but you you mentioned to
me that um the word anti-semitism
doesn't really like doesn't translate
very well in arabic
yeah because it's a
it's it's common sense there no just
kidding yeah
but
but
the
i mean jelly and anti-semitism is a
western terminology to describe because
supposedly
the arabs and the jews came from both
ishmael they have the same ancestor so
they're both viewed as
from as as the same people
and there yeah we don't use the term
semite for
um
however i mean the the right word
actually well that's there's a very
interesting story about the barry weiss
book because of the fact that
anti-semitism and and many of these
things are very common the way
mainstream culture um is that
the book publisher was like okay i
cannot publish that book like i cannot
print it because that's just like a it's
a death sentence really just to print
that book that's like
two months i think was it two months or
nine months
that's no two to three months after an
author was killed
for publishing a positive book about
jewish history in the middle east his
name is masala if i mentioned him in my
event with an event with barry
and so he was like i'm not going to be
able to publish the book physically but
i'm going to do we have underground
reading book reading clubs that we meet
in which we actually discuss many of
these books that are not allowed to be
said and published out loud and he's
like i'm willing to do that and and
that's the the the kind of the
especially when the subjects of of
anti-semitism and things like rise rise
uh generally you get the accusation that
you're working for zionists and you're
working for
israel and things like that and in many
countries in the middle east that's
considered treason so treason the
punishment is death
so as a result there is very little
conversation about these subjects um
even though now it's much much higher
especially after the the abrahamic
accords in which the arab governments
now
are are doing pushing against could you
talk a little bit about you know when we
talk about the middle east and certainly
in the u.s a lot of times it's just this
kind of vague blob that we can kind of
identify in the map but where are the
places that are more receptive to kind
of and i don't want to say western
values because you know the west isn't
particularly good at a lot of this
either but things like pluralism
tolerance freedom of speech what what
are the places where
where you guys are working in the arab
language arabic language world that are
most receptive to
what we might call liberalism
it's actually the places that don't
really enforce the law very well
ironically
um you know i i if you the places that
that
quite regularly censor stuff like a very
long list of you know import controls
and like just pressures on on publishers
would be like egypt syria
um iraq for whatever reason i think they
don't really enforce the law so
that's why it's a bit more of a wild
wild west and and you know black markets
are huge in in in the arabic world and
and not just for books anything that you
know that's banned it's it's whole it's
non-halal meats it's like underground
strip clubs right like things like that
underground strip club yeah
this stuff exists like you know
yeah i mean melissa is absolutely right
in terms of the i mean the more there is
less
kind of government control uh however
when there's less government control
means there's more militias so that's
where where things are about chaotic but
also because of less government control
means more freedom of speech
so that these are where things are kind
of
when the the government is busy fighting
the militias and things like that to the
way they don't have the time really to
enforce
um even though that constitution for
example has restrictions on things that
are ruining social cohesion or things
like that uh same with lebanon and other
places in terms of i mean the only
country that's kind of institutionally
i would say more pronto liberalism is
tunisia um which is also the
ground zero in the arab spring yes right
um and that's and just to some extent is
actually the result of effort like us
the the tunisian actually the dictator
at the time uh
established a translation movement
mainly to translate french material
because tunisia north africa tends to be
closer to france than than us which is
more were under the british control and
the the more french controlled occupied
territories in north africa there were
translation efforts to bring
kind of french ideals to to these
nations and and one of those stories
that were succeeded is tunisia where
actually they have a
at least in principle they have a
version of la cita which is a secular
secular uh uh belief and and also the
the fact of i mean
kind of could there come we can make
comparison between a french constitution
the us constitution in terms of the bill
of rights
um and so they have some of that
that goes back and forth but but that's
like the only country where
it's been institutionalized and which
like we can't call western or light in
the thought but the the countries where
it's not where i said the chaotic
countries um i find them to be actually
the most the word there's gonna be the
most uh revolution saudi arabia to their
credits um is actually evolving to some
again it's like there are people can
pick and choose of social liberalism i
mean you can have the economy without
the freedom of speech and you can so
it's not everything so like there you
just pick and choose which one uh you
want and some of the countries there
try to pick like some things like
economic liberalization but not much on
the freedom of press so so it's there is
a lot of nuance it depends on which
countries is more
um but even saudi arabia is is
progressing i would say towards more
social
reform at least um you guys are also you
have over the past year since the uh
withdrawal in afghanistan i guess you've
started operations in afghanistan can
you talk a little bit about what you're
doing in afghanistan and how that's
working out
we're doing a few things um so we've
expanded into kind of uh trying to find
journalists in afghanistan especially
the ones you know left behind where he's
still able to tell stories
because you know we see cultural
exchange as a two-way street it's not
just about getting
books in english translating in arabic
so that they can read western
authors
but it's also the other way there are
stories you know there are things going
on in that part of the world that we
need to know about and you know we've
now moved on to the next current thing
and the press is no longer interested in
what's going on in afghanistan it's
ukraine and russia or it's i don't know
will smith's slap at the oscar whatever
whatever it is we do have priorities
here exactly oh it's that now it's the
will smith uh no now it's the johnny
depp amber heard trial probably that's
the current thing but um will you be
translating that into arabic i hope
because then
i think that happens all the time there
but in the other way um so what what are
you you're uh you're finding journalists
in afghanistan and bringing their work
to a western audience yes um you're also
working with girls schools right can you
talk about that
yeah so uh
we're working with anything underground
um and mainly with the but most of the
weather and the crabs right yeah um that
that's gonna be that's the new program
i'm discussing right now but
the
the
the main thing is i mean when we started
is is is actually been helping people
getting out so me and melissa were
involved in a lot of conversations to to
how big that happened but the
evacuations yeah the evacuations but the
main thing we're doing is other than
hiring a lot of these translators who
are left out by the by the us withdrawal
uh is that we are funding um a lot of
underground schools so as you know the
not elementary post elementary schools
right now is banned for girls across
afghanistan uh the taliban which is
supposedly now they said they're just
fyi just to talk about u.s foreign
policy the disastrous one is that the
group that negotiated in qatar is not
the same group that's rolling up
afghanistan right now so america was
talking to the wrong people so
the
the people eventually end up being
ruling is actually not the same people
we negotiated with um so those people
what we negotiate with said oh google's
going to be open girls are going to go
to school et cetera the ones who
actually were in control were like no
the moment they are in power then we
want to reinforce the the same rules
that they had uh before when they ruled
before 2001. so uh
what i think one of the most powerful
quotes that i got from there is i asked
one of those teachers i'm like hey why
are you doing this like you're putting a
lot of your life at risk i mean i'm
crazy enough to do it when i was 15 but
you're like have a family and things
like that she's always like facial when
you taste freedom and know what it's
like you want to give it to other people
and this is kind of the type of
and this is and this is kind of yeah the
type of people that we work with and
empower because
uh and unfortunately many of these
people don't
know how to navigate all of the
bureaucracy and know how to fill with 50
page report and things like that so
they're they're teachers there are
people who especially teachers like in a
country that's really devastated by war
um so it when we are constantly
supporting we're actually expanding this
program uh at the beginning we wanted to
kind of test it see how it was going uh
we're getting a lot of positive feedback
and now the goal is to is to really i
think i think education is especially
educational education is one of the best
ways to screw that other one uh they
they have obsession with this for them
it's like um
i mean they're authoritarians on
steroids and and there's nothing bothers
them more than girls education and we're
gonna continue doing that until they get
defeated
i believe it was christopher hitchens
who actually said um
the the single best thing you can do to
to cure poverty is to educate women
and uh yeah i think i think that's very
true um of what we're seeing in the
middle east one of the other things that
we're doing is also expanding the
wikipedia project
into pashtundari so you know we've been
translating i think the the official
statistic is that when we first started
17
of the um the wikipedia pages that you
read in in english is available in
arabic
so imagine you know how small your your
knowledge sphere is
if you were reading something and try to
look something up on wikipedia and all
you had was just that subset of what we
have
um and uh so
that that was in arabic and now we've
expanded to to do um pashto and dari as
well and so faze always has this you
know he made always made this comment
about how
um for what 20 years we were in
afghanistan and we didn't bother
to put in um a wikipedia entry of like
women's rights or feminism
in pasta
how does that work in a country like
afghanistan what is the percentage of
people who have internet access probably
probably mostly through mobile phones
um but you know so how does
you know who are the people who have
that and are they mostly in cities are
they in rural areas is it you know how
do you kind of
figure that out
so um
funnily enough like that when we wanted
the mouth conversations is is even
though i've never been to afghanistan i
know more about afghanistan than many
people the state department which is
i guess shocking but not really um and
mainly i mean there are major cities in
afghanistan the one that the u.s or to
people most familiar with this kabul the
capital city and that's where there's a
high penetration of the internet there's
there's a significant
education for the most part um and then
the other one is herat which is the one
closer to the iranian borders um and
that's also tends to have a significant
part of the internet the pashtu
area is is mostly in the south and this
is where most of the taliban is from um
it's actually all the taliban is smashed
too but but the but there might have
some mercenaries from other races that
do some of the work and that became
actually a priority for us is that in
terms of language the the the first
language in afghanistan is it's called
dari what's the reality is farsi the
same language spoken in iran and the
great thing about iran and became being
a civilization and even the part of
afghanistan so that part of the
population is exposed to at least some
segment of the population of ideas the
pasture one is is the one that's the
most difficult and that's the kind of
the the borders of with pakistan and
that's where
um really a significant amount of
extremism what's what's really
interesting about the wikipedia piece is
that there is actually a heavy usage of
wikipedia pashtu
but there is very little articles on it
so what what's what's interesting is
like there are some languages in which
um like there are the the the people
don't know wikipedia even exists and
there's barely any traffic but wikipedia
pastor has a lot of traffic for the
website
but really doesn't have
almost any content about anything
meaningful i mean they they have a lot
of
uh you know only be begrudging but but
really the the fact is that
most of the
i mean as also mentioning is that the
things that they actually need
in my opinion if i was the policymaker
at the time was the fact that they need
exposure away of ideas away from their
little bubble um and the fact they would
need to be introduced i mean if there's
country that really needs pluralism is
afghanistan it's a very multicultural
people of different ethnicities and
different religions and subsects and and
stuff like that it's really the center
of the world in central asia and and so
they're they're their country of multi
like military ethnicities and they
definitely need some a dose of pluralism
because the most of the conflict is
about the fact some of it is religious
but actually a significant part of it is
ethnic and and that there are some
groups want to take over the other and
so that's to some extent became a
priority for us and and
what's really a theme of all of our
content is critical thinking it's really
just empowering people to think for
themselves other than really just
pushing content the idea is how can we
make people
really think before and and that's
how do you do that
i mean that's you know something people
struggle with everywhere right yeah like
what what is a text or what is a
practice that you try to make it make it
simple i mean really the the
generally i studied critical thinking in
college and and really the the idea is
that
it's to get people to really use to
think to to have to appreciate the
concept of thinking and not
uh and understand more that you actually
the the easiest thing to fool is the
human it's really like there are a lot
of tricks when you teach people the
tricks of how they are being fooled from
how confirmation bias works and how
hindsight biax works and all of these
logical fallacies when you show
like pretty much everybody is a victim
to one fallacy or the other and the
moment you kind of communicated in that
way is that
this is in a way your way to prevent
yourself from being fooled
like there are so many sales tactics all
of that stuff if you use some just basic
critical thinking you're able to save
yourself from a lot of nonsense that's
on the and everything everybody's trying
to sell you something and there's a lot
of nonsense everywhere so i think is
that if we're teaching it uh in a very
simple way many of our videos are very
short it's been written
they've had some of them actually have
three million views 2.5 million views
it's it's the goal is to really uh make
it simple that and i think
we i think we should be able to uh one
of my dreams is that now that we have
some success stories in the middle east
you mentioned that it's something that
needed overseas i think we should use
some of that experience and and maybe
could be useful in this country but but
really i we will welcome that
you know but let's talk uh before we get
to uh i want to talk about the nband
books uh campaign you're doing before we
go to the audience but first let's do a
little biographical sketch uh faisal you
talked a little bit about growing up in
baghdad um
what was it like under saddam hussein
and your your father was i mean he was
not an actor actively in revolt but he
talked to you about you know this this
guy's kind of nuts
yeah so um
so i was my my dad was an orthopedic
surgeon
which i guess was a plus and a negative
is that because doctors get forced to
um to go to war and
and
at the same time there was 1991 there
was a revolution happened in iraq
between a lot of between the kurds in
the north and then the shias in the
south and then the the the province that
my dad grew up in was actually taken
over by the militia that it was actually
revolt against
so he has a lot of stories about having
to to in a way work with both patients
and both of them are killing each other
and then after that saddam hussein use
chemical weapons and all
all forms of that to to get rid of those
militias and so that there is the saddam
that i grew up with i mean saddam went
through multiple phases the first one
being and i went through the country
western phase of saddam
yes
the yeah
non-binary saddam but
um the
the uh
the the first yeah the first phase was
was he was an arab nationalist that he
was more of a secular
guy and then after that
after the iraq iran war he started the
war with america and then he made it a
war between good and evil of of iraq
being an islamic state against the
secular atheistic west and that's the
reason why we have the god is great in
our flag it actually was installed in
1991 it wouldn't exist before it was a
socialist uh so talk about the worst mix
like you got uh you got the the two
worst ideologies and then the so so the
one that i grew up with was actually a
very religious saddam so we actually had
what i grew up in like in monterey
school cetera there was something called
the faith campaign actually the new york
times did a very good article explaining
if you started the faith campaign iraq
you will see
like the
when when when isis came up actually
there were a lot of people who came as a
result of the faith campaign because
then that was in a way like
institutionalizing religion a very
specific sect which is the salafi sunni
islam
and that eventually when and and that
was kind of saddam trying to prepare
um so the the saddam i grew up with was
actually non-secular he was hyper
religious uh he was high personally
there were
specific things that shias can do it
cannot do um didn't he at one point he
translated the quran or did an
introduction where he put his blood in
he brought the quran with his blood
which eventually actually that's one of
my dad's secrets that he wasn't able to
republic like he so my dad at the
hospital was seeing a lot of people
donating blood so it was actually not
his blood oh my god
but so he got a couple of people he's
got a couple things think about using
his blood in the ink of the crayon and
it's no so even that's fake news so so
and then he started becoming a novelist
at his last uh he saw he has the
best-selling novel in iraqi history yeah
which is which is but you got to give it
to them i mean people didn't have to buy
that it's difficult and
and yeah it didn't study marketing
either so
um so and actually that's another story
i mean there's a lot of stories to share
but they actually forced that uh during
the sanctions the salary of even a
doctor was like three dollars a month so
they took a dollar of my dad's salary to
get the shitty book the novel
um
and then the the they forced another one
they took another dollar and so you're
like the the
from my end i mean i grew up in the area
where saddam hussein generals used to
live in so
when the u.s
war happened
my neighborhood switched from that to al
al-qaeda within a second because many of
these people after the disappointment of
the iraqi army
so my neighborhood moved from a purely
residential kids playing soccer stuff
into an area where zarqawi and maine
later al-qaeda used to chill out
and and my neighbor was actually i guess
it's like he can he was playing all
sides so one day he's with the americans
the other day it was al-qaeda so so so
you never
and most like what i
think was very scary
really is
is that saddam first and then after that
is the militias is that they make you
fear your own best friend
so one of the reasons why actually i
ended up on death list was was my
colleague in high school was the one who
reported me who was his cousin who was a
member of al-qaeda or some of his
relatives so in ways like you have to
like talk about cancer culture on
steroids or is that you have to
constantly fear what you're saying
that's why like when i'm here i'm always
very expressive because that was like a
luxury to to be able because you never
know that you might end up on the wrong
list and with the same saddam hussein it
was born institutionalized when you have
like out of four adults one is in their
intelligence services
so there are even rumors of like people
getting divorced
because they thought that their wife is
part of the regime or their husband part
of the regime or their best friend is
part of the regime so like it's
authoritative it gets into your head
like after i mean my parents in a way
like who lived a lot a lot of decades
like this regime and so as many people
is like
for for them is like they're traumatized
by like it's authoritarianism like on
the on their brains like it gets to your
core in which everybody is have to be
freaked out of everybody you never know
if this person is is a terrorist you
never know if this person is part of the
government
and
then when when that regime was removed
it just became absolute chaos because
like people were living in a prison both
a real prison because they're not
allowed to leave the country and at the
same time a mental prison
and and so this is like
the
like the conditions in a way i'm hoping
i'm doing a good job and explaining it
but it's it's a bit harsher than
actually what i'm saying this is the
conditions in which like there are
millions of people tens of millions that
grow up under and
then it's like when you look close by
look to syria and things like that it's
a lot of similar stuff like when i uh
been to syria and talked to a lot of
syrians that they say oh i could relate
to you i'm like
[ __ ] that's that's the worst thing to
relate to but chuck you used heavy metal
music as a way of speaking back or
stepping through this could you just
touch briefly on what you got out of
that because heavy metal people almost
everywhere are
reviled right they're a subculture
they're seen as weirdos yeah um i mean i
guess i'm in that category too but um
but yes so so as a result of this kind
of of authoritarian culture and regime
so like there's the both of them there
there was kind of the rise of the
counter culture and
the the kind of the metal
scene i mean for for good and bad it was
viewed first as like satanist right so
that's like the worst thing that the
religious hate uh and at the same time
it i mean lyrics wise and things like
that was always about kind of screw to
the to the outside world uh that's why
they scream so much right um so then
there was i mean
with that
actually get associated a lot of like
intellectualism so when there is kind of
heavy metal underground concert there's
also books being discussed and so so all
of these things are merged together in
the context of there is this mainstream
culture which is
uh kind of
flippy uh one day is especially in my
neighborhood it was like one day with
iran the other week with al qaeda and
then people keep switching so that's the
mainstream culture and then there is
like this kind of community
uh that that really is against all of
that and and that's where kind of the
metal music and and really the
expression artistic and expression of of
the revolts
um and actually national geographic did
a very good documentary on some of my
friends it's called heavy metal and
baghdad and and you can see like some of
these underground places i'm talking
about and that was young me
um i guess i was i was in a heavy metal
festival in germany and there's all
these germans the big ones i was with
this guy
and
so i i was i definitely lived
i'm enjoying it still but there's all
this
now actually just to relate to all of
what we're saying is like kind of
libertarian classical liberal whatever
you you identify with
um but i will say like the
anti-socialist anti-theocratic
theme is now the kind of the
counterculture so now there are like
bookstores and that's one of like some
of the bookstores that i made we're
looking forward to uh you translating ac
dc you're done with john stewart mill
obviously would have been a metalhead
right
yeah i mean
i mean to our surprise like
these things are so
available right now
like
is that i mean actually this is not
really metals like slick grog
yeah i mean it's really acoustic yeah i
mean i mean that's that's me exactly
like i mean
it's folk music it's like more like a
background music for me i need i need
more uh
but
the
yeah i mean all of these things uh
there's even now like local metal bands
in syria and all that it's in and add to
that is that now
this kind of in
intel even like an iraq club in syria
i mean not
not necessarily the best example to some
people but it is definitely
uh because again it's like they
and part of the reason why they relate a
lot to like kind of the enlightenment
era i was having a conversation with
with the pub publisher is that like the
enlightenment era came during religious
wars right it came during
all of that and that's what's really
happening in the middle east right now
so even though some of the language in
the books of voltaire and and and
rousseau and so it's kind of difficult
to comprehend in 21st century language
but in a way it's far more relatable
than
like the culture wars here in america or
even though they made their way to the
middle east which was
just one example before is that there
was a school that was built and it was
like
it's a girls school but it says for
people who identify as girls
and people that have no [ __ ] idea
what that means like what does that like
like we're talking to the middle east
and people there so like so so people
say the people actually don't know how
to translate this so so definitely the
cultural war in america have
have made it over there but people were
very confused melissa talk about you're
from singapore and your father was who's
recently deceased sorry for your loss
but he was also highly placed in the
government what was what was growing up
in singapore like uh because it's an
authoritarian country but distinct from
a kind of what faisal was talking about
in iraq i mean very distinct because
it's a benevolent dictatorship um and
you know i mean my childhood couldn't be
more different from these guys
the the one thing we did share in common
was the lack of freedom of speech which
is you know
the what he described as the weight of
censorship on your shoulders to always
walk on eggshells to not be able to
really
speak your mind and and and i think the
most pernacious
um end point of that is when you start
to self-censor
and that's what happens uh growing up
there
and
but by all accounts it is very
prosperous it is a very stable country
um life is good you know especially
considering what goes on here in the u.s
is like very high crime rates um
singapore is kind of
a paradise to raise children and if you
value safety and and stability
and prosperity so i mean in that sense i
have no complaints but
growing up there um you know i
i joked before and even though it's not
that much of a joke my dad was kind of
he worked for the singapore government
in particular military intelligence
and he was asian dick cheney um he
you know justified all the time torture
and so you know i always had this banter
back and forth with him and so you know
most people
means you really did clean your room
when i told you
yeah i really did
um but but in most people's factory
settings tend to be you know probably
well here in new york probably more on
the liberal side and then you kind of
you know
uh grow up and you know maybe exposed to
different ideas but uh but for me it was
actually the other way my dad was always
very was kind of a died in the world
near conservative and and so
um you know he justified a lot of the
repressive policies uh of his government
and in in singapore um speech has always
been very highly regulated uh you know
under the guise of preserving social and
racial harmony and that's something that
we're hearing a lot more today here in
the u.s where you have
books that are censored for the same
reason the adventures of huck finn dr
seuss uh recently uh luke luke uh you
know have been they're the adventures of
the cavemen
kung fu caveman exactly the time
traveling yeah which were removed for uh
depicting certain racial stereotypes or
you know kind of um
in terms of huck finn is the same same
kind of reasoning and but it's also
singapore is a very new country right
yes and i mean how does that factor into
what is it i mean you're kind of like
second generation or third generation
being born after singapore was
independent yeah yeah but it was a
british colony for for a very long time
and then it changed hands under world
war ii was run by the japanese who took
over then it went back to um to the
british and singapore was like one of
the only countries that have gained
independence reluctantly
like it got expelled from malaysia
didn't really want to be on its own so
you know most countries have this desire
um i think the if you look at number of
countries and in time
you only see that increasing because
countries keep splitting up like in the
last few years we've seen south sudan
split from sudan east timor split from
indonesia so there's always been this
um kind of like self-determination right
like like people singapore says no they
didn't want to and and primarily because
it was a very small country um didn't
have natural resources
the the founder of modern singapore felt
that
it was better off
um being attached to malaysia or being
part of a federation kind of like the
united states in a way um and that's
partly because they're afraid of being
taken over by either china or exactly
past japanese exactly
but does singapore give law uh give the
lie i mean in your reading to you know
there's a broad western belief and that
milton friedman probably articulated
this most famously of saying that when
you get a certain level of economic
prosperity political
uh freedom tends to go you know tends to
uh come into play because people who are
wealthy want to be able to spend their
money on the things they want they want
to live a certain lifestyle do you think
that is likely to happen in a place like
singapore i i've the reason i didn't
view the rise of china in the same
way that
many in the u.s foreign policy circles
and even government did for i don't know
decades
was precisely because i grew up there
and i knew or at least i i've
known this for a fact that
i've seen people achieve riches and and
you know enjoy
luxury
actually
go the other way on freedom they they
think that it's actually um
it actually harms the society overall
and it's not just singapore i think the
gulf states are also you know another
example of
of a place where
uh people have very high standard of
living there i mean new york is really a
[ __ ] country compared to some of
these places if you go to our subways
um and
and and these you know what they want is
not it's not these abstract freedoms
it's very difficult to convince people
of abstract freedoms like freedom of
speech and you know and and um
for example singapore also does not have
freedom of press so if you look at the
uh rankings globally it's 158th out of
180 in in the world so it's behind
afghanistan libya and russia
um
to be able to apply for
to publish anything you need to apply
for a license and recently they put out
a bill called the prevention of online
misinformation and and falsehoods which
is the government can basically force if
you post something on social media can
force you to apologize retract clarify
um which basically sounds like you know
we're not far from it either right with
a
ministry of disinformation it's going
there yeah let's
they're going to start saying like you
have to stop using filters on your
instagram and you're not i agree with
that you have to you have to show your
body mass or something that will help a
lot
let's talk uh about n-band books the
campaign that you guys are doing because
that
you know is is coming out of that could
i mean that's uh melissa just to uh push
a little on that i mean that seems like
a ridiculous statement to say that you
know the stupid thing that the dhs
in america just
announced and screwed up the
announcement uh over the weekend like
they were trying to talk about we're
going to do this but then they didn't
even actually reply to the associated
press and other places who had asked
what you were going to be doing but that
kind of thing to the type of censorship
that you're talking about or
what faisal was talking about can you
explain the link
that you worry about in that kind of
behavior i think i want to make a
distinction there really are different
levels of censorship um in faizal's
country
if you say the wrong thing you get
killed
that's one level of censorship that's
one level waiting he's an american
citizen okay i'm sorry
that was a microaggression so i i need
to be sent to the gulag
um microaggression sorry but you know in
in singapore if you had said something
that disrupted social or religious
harmony
you would be at most jailed so no
killing at least so better but that is
still
insane
insane okay but in the united states
the manifestation of censorship and
cancer culture totally different the
consequences are different your first
amendment protects you at least from the
government
but what you have is censorship at even
different levels to not have a book at a
library is very different you know from
not having a book uh published to begin
with because the publisher decides to
retract it as
is what happened with dr seuss's estate
very recently
um and the dave pilkey and the dave
pilkey if you have kids or if you were a
kid you might remember him as the author
of the captain underpants also highly
sensitive which was always being
challenged
in libraries yeah yeah
and and so
you know in the us the ala the american
library association puts out these like
you know list of highly challenged books
some of them are surprising every year
like i think harry potter is one of the
most challenged books because of uh
witchcraft and promoting um he never
should have ended up with ginny weasley
come on that's something we all agree on
that
i mean we we all i'm sure have you know
a sense of like if i was a censor i
would definitely you know prohibit uh
50 shades of gray that's just a crap
book it shouldn't be in existence we all
have some sense of like what we would
censor but but
i think
i think you know whether or not a book
is in a curriculum whether or not it's
in the school library versus whether or
not it's in a public library it's very
different and when you register a
complaint when you challenge a book what
you're doing is actually
um depriving other people of actually
reading that book it's one thing for you
not to read the books one thing for you
to you know tell your children or to
guide your children and be there when
they're checking out a book but it's
another thing altogether to say like i
don't want anybody else to read it and i
think that's where the the danger and
the parallels to cancel culture really
come in and let's be honest some of
these challenges that are going on right
now in school libraries
um
debate on on you know whether or not
these books should be removed
who is it really gonna affect like three
asian kids who go to the library like
who else is who else is in the library
they're all on tick tock like it's not
even an effective strategy now you know
like like they're just getting their
information elsewhere so i don't even
think maybe you guys can start
translating dr seuss into english and
distributing it for free and grammar
schools around the country
um talk about i mean the nbandbooks.org
site is is really kind of spectacular
and you and you jump from
uh you know
kind of ridiculous examples uh including
the way winnie the pooh is banned in
china
to more
i mean i guess that's not
inconsequential the reasons for that are
ridiculous right that she has been
people make fun of him and say he looks
like winnie the pooh so
christopher robin takes it on the chin
there but
what
you know what is the progression from
the kind of banal examples that we might
be talking about here to the more
you know serious stuff
yeah so so nbandbooks.org which i
recommend everyone here goes there um is
an advocacy campaign really to to
educate people about global censorship
and and also really that the spectrum in
which in in which the censorship is uh
there are
um i think and that's really my my
personal belief and there's a letter
that i've written on really kind of try
to compare between all the examples is
that the impulses of authoritarianism i
mean we've always had a history of that
and from the beginning of human history
there was this impulse
to to to regulate speech and to regulate
thoughts
um and
it takes different forms um and and i
think that if the i mean the example
that i grew up with which is like one
out of four is in the intelligence
services and
in a way it if if you think about it
it's kind of
very similar to some extent when you are
a minority perspective in in in a
city like new york city uh in which
the outcome is still negative i mean
there's obvious degrees of negativity
um so however that kind of extreme
version i think and that's i don't think
being i'm being far-fetched here is that
i can definitely see the roots of
authoritarianism over here in terms of
people intolerance different
perspectives
uh the fact that other people i mean i
mean i've studied a lot about civil wars
and i lived in one and the first thing
of civil wars is that you dehumanize the
other group that's the first instinct
after that everything is permissible
because you can act on self defense
and you can definitely see your roots of
it over here in terms of kind of
republican democrat et cetera et cetera
the great thing is we have a rule of law
and there's nypd let the nypd take a
one-week break and let's see what
happens
um i'm not surprised if if america will
snap like this and then what happens is
that bad guys a very small fraction of
bad guys gonna start killing each other
and then because of tribal nature people
will be like at least he's better than
the other side and that's the same thing
that we actually when you talk about
censorship you always get what if you
are talking about the censorship from
the left like the knee-jerk reaction is
well how about the right they do this
too and then it's like so you can
definitely see
that that the seeds for authoritarianism
and tribal thinking is already taking
rules um
so
the the when we show the kind of the
extreme examples of
is that we're trying to educate is like
be careful what you wish for
uh this is this is the end that the
civil wars and the and the censorship
and the minister of information and on
the intelligence services jsq this is
like the most extreme but this is goes
from a spectrum i mean in europe
there's actually far more regulations of
freedom of speech
and some of them are actually very
stupid and
and they are also trying to to use force
in in so in terms of you saying the
wrong thing um and
so there are
you if you look at the spectrum of like
i don't know afghanistan being the most
extreme in which girls don't got school
and and books pretty much
all books are banned to some extent in
afghanistan and during iraq during
saddam hussein was there are more books
that are banned that are books that are
right
uh so that's iraq prior 2003. so this is
like the most extreme example but
if if
you always ask questions like the people
there are not special
like how did they get there
everything that they they get there is
is can everything happen in places where
where it goes from freedom to into
authoritarianism so really i think there
is great message in this
advocacy movement in this project
they're actually mainly targeted towards
the west which is be careful what you
wish for and really educate them about
the effects of censorship
and and the intersection between
censorship and authoritarianism because
i think many people
here don't get that
and they think that
that that's so uh this is very so i mean
even the subject of
misinformation and combative
misinformation that's how many
authoritarian regimes start censoring is
that it's always a slippery slope they
they start with this
it never ends there in your experience
never ends in your experiences was it
awesome you know part of the way kind of
a new wave of censorship is going
through here
is that it is about helping people who
would feel marginalized by discourse so
the reason we want to regulate twitter
is because one group is going after a
marginalized group and saying bad things
about them so it's it isn't that we want
to shut down speech and thought it's
that we want to protect
you know marginalized groups that will
leave the public square because they're
being chased out is that the experience
in places like singapore or iraq or is
it more
fundamentally about we want to have a
unified kind of identity and we're just
going to wipe people out i mean i think
that's always been the excuse it's very
easy to sell
censorship to the public using safetyism
using you know this is going to be
dangerous the speech is dangerous it's
going to disrupt the stability that you
know
but at the end of the day it is also a
tool
for authoritarians to horde power every
strong man out there today
is censoring and
that's why i think it's a misnomer we
call them strong men you know but how
can they be strong when they're afraid
of mere ideas like if you look at the
long list of of books banned in places
like russia and in china and the middle
east
it is long and i think the value of of
of kind of highlighting banned books
is to look individually at all these
regimes and and and i think it's
revealing because it reveals kind of
what are their anxieties when you look
at the list of titles that are banned
for example during pinochet's chile
the book that was uh very
i'm going to go out on limb and say with
the atkins diet book
he really gained a lot of weight over
his time in power actually i did not
know that that's fat shaming um but
but in this case it's warranted
yeah
but the book that was uh banned at the
time was was a book called how to read
donald duck
and it was a book that was a marxist
critique of disney as a vector for
exporting american corporate and
cultural
imperialism um
and
that book was banned by the pinochet
regime so you can see kind of like the
anxieties of of of these uh rulers that
have authoritarianism so before we ended
up for uh audience q a melissa i have to
ask you them what is your anxiety about
50 shades of grey that you were calling
for
terrible wait it's just yeah that's what
we get writing it's just awful and the
writing and it's just embarrassing that
this exists and that women like it i'm
embarrassed for my gender
i mean it's hard to go from there to
what can i say but uh i mean
i'm gonna say something
gosh let's
make it difficult but i just wanna like
remind people of what the enlightenment
is i mean the enlightenment came in as a
principle that you as an individual
matter and you have
the ability to trade and you have the
ability to think for yourself and there
are a lot of people who don't like this
idea
and we have to defend it in any way we
can and stand for all of the values of
this
this
era that that came in from the
enlightenment era and set for it today
whether through translation making it
available to other people and also if it
needs to stand for this value over here
that i thought a country that get this
[ __ ] together uh i will do the same so
thank you very much all right thank you
thanks nick
um let's uh have some audience questions
please wait for malik to uh bring the
microphone to you okay
and if you want to you can identify
yourself or you can use a pseudonym
oh my name is arf and i'm from pakistan
actually and the question i have is
uh regarding the books when you
translate you know like i also send
these books to pakistan for kids to read
whatever and there are much fewer
institutional and legal constraints
there you know and actually a lot of
these books are buy in pakistan because
they're cheaper but it's hard to have
people read them because
they don't resonate with them they are
so far removed from their cultural moral
historical whatever framework they have
you know their wealth and chong that it
is just very alien to them you know how
do you and i like the idea that you have
like simplified translations of uh for
like pashto for example you know but how
do you get people is that like something
that you struggle with uh that's the
first second question i have is actually
these are more political and i wanted to
ask some iraqi and i don't know any
you're the only one like how do they i'm
going to be the prime minister official
prime minister quickly
how did the iraqi people feel about the
us and the war after all these years
what's the perception thank you um i'm
gonna answer this very quickly it all
depends who you ask but mainly um if you
go to the northern part of iraq the
kurdistan region it's generally tend to
be very positive
if you go down everything goes downhill
so
the uh i mean there were times in the
northern part of iraq in which the us
didn't have to go with any arms and they
can walk around
um in terms of i mean pakistan i mean as
you're familiar there are blasphemy laws
in pakistan and that people end up if
they convert to different religions or
things like that um so there's
definitely a lot of institutional
restrictions on on thoughts and the
for for i think it's like when i was
talking about the kind of the
enlightenment era it is in a way a lot
of relatable like for example one of the
very i think one of the most food
articles this month in our work was the
33-year war the one in the protestant of
the catholics in europe
and
it happened because like when a famous
blogger and i think it was in in syria
tweeted about this which is like now
we're having our phase of the 33 year
war again european example protestant
catholic christian most people don't
know where christians christianity even
have different sex
but it was relatable like they can see
that there's some some example there um
and
there we have a specific program i mean
in addition to the fact that the
creative relatable content of actually
highlighting arab liberal thinkers which
is called bil arabi which is a semi
which is like liberalism in arabic but
we all made it with arabic which is
funded by atlas network and frederick
norman i saw there's atlas people here
so big fan uh and the idea is that we
actually highlight people from the
region who believe in these ideals not
not just translating
but rather have people who really made
their own thinking using local examples
and be familiar with the nuances of the
region who can explain it
much better way than a translation ever
would thank you next question
hi uh it's debbie here thanks for the uh
shout out to atlas um hello debbie hi
so i have a i have a double barrel
question as well um one is
um what is your reach like for example
do you know how many um copies of on
liberty have been downloaded
um and then secondly
um are
a
pre-cleared pre-translated
classical liberal texts
uh translated to pashtun and arabic of
value to you
so again you want to join
yeah so uh atlas network has funded a
lot of translations of of uh classical
liberal materials so actually we
share we have them in our library uh
because we have a
very massive reach
i mean our page library website itself
has one million followers
and then the we acquired because of my
connections we acquired a lot of
connections of of pages social media
pages that have now six million
followers so our reach in terms of
people seven million um in terms of
countries egypt morocco algeria iraq
uh and lebanon i think are the top five
countries for terms of
and yes we we have measurement in our
website about uh
people downloading and and i would like
to actually
uh get in more because what i'm also
interested to know what sticks
uh in terms of um the one of the people
from atlas uh
um
you're probably familiar with it from
morocco he actually like explains the
free market in very simple terms and his
podcast the one we did with him was the
most viral one it had like 500 000 views
um so that was kind of like oh okay
let's highlight more people like that uh
so we do our best to actually see the
data and what's what really sticks and
and try to make it as simple as possible
because the ideas of freedom as you all
know it's tend to be very abstract tend
to be a lot of connection especially
when you have really no experience of
freedom especially many people have
lived their entire life in the
authoritarianism and for them to treat
them something they see on youtube
so so we really want to do our best to
kind of like make it as simple as
possible and see what sticks and and
work on that there's a brainwashing
aspect to get over too because i think
not only is freedom abstract but it's
also tainted by these education systems
and their governments
that freedom is a western concept and
anything that is western is needs to be
derided so there is that hurdle that
that we need to kind of cross and then
the other issue is also that um i think
when we start circulating books like
ebooks on telegram which is how the
black market operates in in the middle
east we can't really track how far that
goes so once we can track like downloads
on a website um but in terms of telegram
itself like how far that actually
spreads like once it's on telegram it's
just
we want it there but you know we don't
know follow up a little bit uh on this
was touched on briefly but you know
overall in the middle east and in
central asia and these are obviously
distinct regions and there's lots of
sub-pockets but
you know the amer american foreign
policy has been disastrous it did not
achieve its stated goals uh you know for
all of the 21st century i mean is that
also a stumbling block
in terms of you know if you're saying
and now from the people who just bombed
and occupied you for 20 years and then
left leaving many of you behind here's a
book about freedom is is that a hurdle
to overcome
or is it or i'm asking because this is
you know we don't we don't hear really
well you know american foreign policy
debates aren't always about domestic
politics really we don't really hear
from the people in the regions you know
for good or bad that we
interact with well i
i just came back from the region and
really the main thing that i think
america lacks is trust right now
especially after the
the afghanistan withdrawal in which many
people now look america as a really bad
ally
um with china with russia
you know what they're gonna get like you
you know so if china makes a policy
russia makes a policy they stick with it
they they they stood with bashar
al-assad and they defended bashar
al-assad to death and and here they are
and he's still in power with america
it's like it's non-binary really he's
like you you one one day you are with
this you rather there you are with that
hillary praises arab springs the next
day she's saying that mubarak is our
ally so in a way is that the us is
definitely viewed as a non-trustworthy
ally the
interesting thing also about the us is
that
u.s also has hollywood and has things
like that that in which it exports its
culture so generally
people are familiar with
america not necessarily from a political
standpoint
um and that's said about iraqis in which
we see the us army but the same time we
see seinfeld so in a way it's like
the the
there is the export of american culture
that's
sometimes is positive and viewed so if
you ask most people they will tell you
it's like i like american people not the
american government i'm guessing and i
think i think the yeah the the policies
they have about them the government is
completely justifiable especially after
the whole disaster i'm assuming that the
soup nazi is the most popular seinfeld
character in iraq from what you were
saying
we need to translate it maybe okay let's
have another question
yeah i guess uh more on the state of
things in the usa my husband is from
hong kong
and i hear
grave concern from our friends there
their democracy has recently been
crushed by the chinese communist party
and my hong kongese friends say to me
are you aware that you're poised in your
country to vote away your democracy
devote away your freedoms that we're
very close
to literally voting away
something so precious and unique
and uh do you share their alarm
i absolutely do um
yeah and hong kong is is i don't know
it's a jewel honestly a beacon of
of what
you know i mean i think it's just such
an important natural experiment because
people always said i mean the the
communist party always said you know
how can
you know that democracy wasn't suited
for for people of asian culture and
asian descent and
and hong kong and taiwan are just
natural rebuttals to that argument and
and hong kong flourishes in so many
aspects of freedom it was at some point
in the 70s and 80s and actually early
90s
just you know produced the best movies
anywhere like they were out producing
hollywood for for a period of time and
their stars were just cultural
phenomenons in their own right and of
course today it's so sad like you look
at someone like jackie chan and he has
to pay lip service
to the the communist party and you know
now he just has to be fully on board the
sea train
um to to see hong kong kind of unravel
in
like right in front of our eyes has it
it should be it should wake people up
um and that it can happen so fast it's
not even a generation it's it's like
just a couple years that we saw you know
the the communist party just march in um
install its its lackeys as leaders
uh the new security law and and change
the culture i mean remember the causeway
booksellers the people who
um
all the dirty tabloid criticisms of the
ccp used to be published in this
in hong kong because it was the only
place that they they could get air time
um and so you you know the the communist
party is like
millions and millions and millions of
people that are that exist in the
political bureau and of course it's not
monolithic there are there are there's
internal descents there are people um
that you know that are publishing all
these like internal dirty secrets and
and the only place they would come out
used to be hong kong um there was a book
publisher a very famous one called
causeway booksellers that used to
publish all this stuff they would
annotate it and they would put out this
this material that was how
we were getting intel on what was going
on in the communist party some of it
obviously is fake news just like twitter
it's it's just in book form
um but but
you know you got a sense of what was
going on because hong kong was free
but you know not only was this guy this
this uh bookseller actually kidnapped
whilst he was in thailand
um and by the way he's not even a
chinese citizen he's actually a swedish
citizen so now swedenborg did not kidnap
him
i have no one in my place
um but yeah to to to see to see kind of
hong kong descend into that is is really
tragic and and
the us
you know as long as it does not value
that um
that uh the freedom of speech and the
freedom of press i think we'll go down
that route as well how would you uh you
know one of the things that comes up a
lot is that hollywood uh and the nba for
example because they're currying or
cultivating a chinese audience they
censor themselves or they restrict their
players from talking
what would be a better response from
from america not not in terms of you
know military power or anything like
that but what what would be a better
cultural response i think it's just
shame you know i mean if you look at at
the actors people like john cena who had
to grovel and apologize in mandarin by
the way his mandarin is really bad it
was embarrassing
um but in a way that makes it better
right
he doesn't even know what he's saying
but he knows he has to apologize right
but it's so cringe to see
you know people who have money and
status here in this country
abide by the
leverage that the chinese government has
purely because of market power because
they have to promote
in his case was fast viewers 9. in the
mba's case it's because the nba has huge
licensing deals in china
um and and it's not just the nba it's
almost every company even apple does it
burton the
ski board skateboarding company does it
um
at the end of the day market power is is
leverage and and the chinese government
knows how to how to wield it they know
how to get concessions and to get
companies to abide by its um
political ideology we have time for one
more quick question
whoever gets the mic
uh can we come up here malik okay it's
got to be a short question it's got to
be a question no double barrelled
questions no three-part
keys go ahead melissa can you uh comment
in that context about elon musk buying
twitter
um
i i mean i think for you know i i don't
want to throw the baby out with the
bathwater i think elon
is doing so many things that are good
for for society and advancing humanity
one of which which by the way i think
has the power to really disrupt
authoritarianism around the world and
that is starlink
right like to have satellites that can
connect the world outside the confines
that are controllable like imagine
starlink versus the great firewall we
may have a chance to to reach you know
the inner recesses of the chinese
population that right now as we speak
revolting
and and rioting
unprecedented right like in shanghai and
shenzhen against very draconian uh
policies
and to drag him
right now because he has you know
certain deals because of tesla with the
chinese market also lithium he needs you
know the company does need the
the rare earth materials that are only
coming from china and so he has to play
nice with the chinese government in some
respects i think the exposure is
is something that we need to keep tabs
on like whether or not if he owns
twitter does the chinese government have
any leverage i saw that recently that
the state uh media person a
person has actually requested elon to
remove because twitter says if you are a
spokesperson for a government it says
like state media
um
and so he requested elon to actually
remove something they tagged him
directly i mean
it's i think it's up to us to to keep
tabs on something like that to make sure
that
that he is not kowtowing to um to the
demands of the chinese government but
otherwise he is he is actually exposed
his business interests his business
deals are leaves him his companies his
ip exposed in china it could end very
badly for him it could end very badly
for tesla but i don't want to discount
the other things that elon is
ideologically um committed to and that
is free speech you know he did famously
say he's a free speech absolutist
um and and also what he's doing with
starlink really has the potential to to
disrupt the
censorship around the world
all right we're going to leave it there
i want to thank faisal syed al-matar and
melissa chan of ideas beyond borders
this is ben the reason interview
thanks for listening thank you for being
here guys
you